hi my name is alexis
and i am digital marketer at the united
laboratory
my professional background is actually
in hospital industry where i worked as a
freelancer massage therapist for six
years
six years is a long time and
professionally i have reached a plateau
i wanted to challenge myself switch to a
different path and digital marketing
wasn't the way to go i lacked political
skills and i think these were simple and
happy bridge the gap i was looking at
several courses
but the digital marketing specialist
master program from simpler human
attention i felt the course was the
perfect springboard to finding a job
especially because it gave me i found a
six-day review of the fleet and prepared
me for interviews as well
within three weeks of completing the
course i was able to find a job
tools like google analytics su ranking
and boost suite has so many more word
coverage that is actually used in tech
industry the recording classes also made
them more engaging
using the self-paced model i could use
my lunch breaks and free time between
appointments to complete the section
managing the course we worked was a
little tricky but the platform has a
feature where you can specify the number
of hours you want to spend on the course
every day so that really helped with
time management and apart from work i'm
very interested in photography and my
favorite area in london to take
photos is showing from entire experience
that one thing that us the mind
constantly may strive to grow
keep you on your feet with the latest
english events and looking out for
opportunities is very important
our skating has become a trending world
now and 10 to 4 reason
we have come to understand that without
upskin
there is no growth
so continuing top skill and better
yourself it will pay off in the hands